quelques gilet jaune dont le brouillard
près de dijon
ces irréductibles tiennent le rond point
mais sans le bloqué ils préviennent les
automobilistes pour la manifestation de
samedi prochain
pour l'instant le mouvement se maintient
avec moins de manifestants plusieurs
dizaines par point de blocage comme ici
à montceau les mines vient moins que
samedi dernier quand 6000 personnes
déferlé jusque dans les rues de dijon
c'est bien ça bloque au moins tout dijon
et puis faut montrer qu'on n'est pas
content avec les idées du gouvernement
sont pas celles du peuple
au fil des jours les rangs pierre sennes
petit à petit mais ce qui se relaie
encore restent déterminés sur les
barrages toute la nuit et jusqu'à l'aube
en essayant de garder une bonne ambiance
on déplore effectivement qui est des
incidents à droite à gauche
c'est ce qui est relativement en plus
c'est en ce moment très médiatisé mais
comme vous pouvez le voir ici ça se
passe une ambiance bon enfant il faut
que ça est bon enfant
pacifiste toujours objectif d gilet
jaune ou tenir au moins jusqu'à samedi
jour où ils espèrent voir leurs rangs
gonfler année vie